[Music]
Justin Bieber still hasn't gotten the
stamp of approval from Selena Gomez's
friends amid rumors set the on-again
off-again couple has broken up again a
[Music]
source tells ET that the actresses
closest pals are not fans of the sorry
singer quote they think he's bad news
for Selena and don't approve of the
relationship adding they think he's a
bad influence on her and she becomes
really dependent on him according to the
source Justin has made an effort to show
he's changed and that their relationship
is different this time
quote he does care what her friends and
family think and has tried to win them
over but some of them are just over it
et previously reported that Selena's
friends and family particularly her
mother man DT fee struggled with the
couple's reunion back in January
since then our source says she's been
trying her best to quote keep the peace
between Justin and her friend circle
quote she's not going to abandon herself
or her friends for Justin that's a big
difference this time around and the only
place her friends really overlap with a
pop star is Church that's been a really
positive thing for them as for the
future of Jelena the source claims quote
Selena is a people pleaser
she hates having people disappointed in
her eventually something will have to
give
[Music]